[Music]
creating in was challenging took me a
while to find the actual character the
challenging bit with Ian in general was
not only had to find his character but
we he was kind of defining what an elf
is in this world there was a desire to
really push them and make them more
unique than human and to make them not
just a human with pointy ears the
problem is an elf is just a human with
pointy ears so we were making all these
creatures with muzzles that look like
donkeys when I'm starting to just draw
shapes I want a silhouette it captures
an emotion that's bold there's always
different tastes the director has kind
of an aesthetic the designers and
artists have an aesthetic what the
back-and-forth is is design and
character and how do those two merge to
create what we need for this story
Matt's doing a million drawings and then
just found one that really felt like Ian
it really captured the idea of an
awkward teen and yet still had this
sweet appeal to it and still felt real
and specific and was wondering if you
wanted to come over and get down on some
cake no that's not something anyone says
12 Holland was really good at the
fumbling teenage stuff I don't I don't
want to play at all she's kind of like a
you know like an awkward teenager who's
trying to find himself in right oh I
didn't know you knew my anyway there's a
lot of hemming and hawing and being
embarrassed if you like parties then I'm
I was gonna do a party what which was
perfect for the character that we needed
actually help push the character in the
right direction that's voice acting
effecting the art affecting the story
everybody kind of improving and finding
this character together